hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime uproar and today i will
be talking about asta's final form in
black clover and what i believe could be
the ultimate evolution of his anti-magic
i think that anti-magic is just the
first stage of asta's true power and i
believe that anti-magic is about to
evolve into black hole magic in this
video i will explain why i believe that
asta's anti-magic will ultimately evolve
into black hole magic and i will also
explain what types of powers and
abilities black hole magic could possess
finally i will take a look at some other
popular theories about asta's final form
and ultimate power along with a special
guest so let's get into it if you guys
enjoy our black lower videos and you
want to see more you know what to do
just leave a quick like and comment it
only takes a second but it helps a lot
with the youtube algorithm and if you're
new to the channel or maybe you watch
our videos but you just haven't taken
the time to subscribe yet do me a quick
favor and make this the video that you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications you can
also hit me up on twitter and instagram
at animeopror finally this video will
contain black lover manga spoilers i am
using all available information from the
manga so please proceed with caution you
have been warned for a long time i've
been intrigued by the star symbolism and
imagery that frequently comes up in
black clover especially when it comes to
osta to name just a few examples the
word osta means divine or star-like in
certain languages osta has a star-like
shape on his headband and of course
osta's devil union form contains a bunch
of star-shaped imagery there is a star
symbol in his eye there is a star-like
symbol on his chest and so on so
naturally a lot of fans were speculating
that maybe asta will eventually unlock
some sort of star magic perhaps star
magic is his original magic which just
didn't awaken yet for whatever reason a
fellow anime youtuber by the name of
broku actually made a full video on this
a while back and be sure to stick around
until the end of the video because i
will be bringing broku in as a guest to
give us his thoughts on asta's final
form and ultimate magic power now this
idea that asta might have star magic was
thrown for a major loop when it was
revealed in chapter 309 that star magic
is actually yuno's original magic the
wind magic that yuno had been using up
to this point actually belonged to licht
and tetia's son who had been
reincarnated inside of him but when yuno
came across the grimoire that had been
originally intended for him within his
native spade kingdom he unlocked a
second magic attribute star magic and
obviously if yuno now has star magic
then tabitha is not going to give that
same magic attribute to asta right well
yes and also no let me explain i believe
that asta and liebe's anti-magic will
eventually evolve into none other than
black hole magic as i said earlier i
think that black hole magic is the
ultimate incarnation the final form if
you will of anti-magic if we consider
the known properties of a black hole
then black hole magic instantly becomes
the ultimate evolution of anti-magic it
is the only logical conclusion now
believe it or not i am not an
astrophysicist and even among the
foremost experts on astrophysics and
quantum mechanics there is still major
disagreement about black holes no one's
ever been close enough to study one
before so a lot of what we know is
completely theoretical thankfully black
clover is a series about magic so we
don't need to worry too much about
scientific accuracy all we need to think
about is how the concept of a black hole
might be used by tabata to create an
overpowered magic evolution for asta a
black hole is a region of space time
where the gravity is so strong that
nothing not even light can escape black
holes can absorb everything around them
including massive objects like stars and
they warp and alter literally everything
in the immediate area including gravity
space and even time it's almost like
black hole magic would be the ultimate
weapon to use against devils who possess
gravity magic spatial magic and time
magic and how is a black hole formed in
the first place black holes are said to
form when massive stars collapse at the
end of their life cycle after a black
hole forms it can continue to grow by
absorbing mass from its surrounding area
so in reality black hole magic would be
a type of star magic black holes are
formed from stars or at least what's
left of stars after they reach the end
of their life cycle and collapse you
know may be the one who possesses star
magic but his rival asta his counterpart
in the story could possess the dark
counterpart of star magic which is black
hole magic this would explain all of the
star symbolism and imagery when it comes
to asta and it would answer a lot of
other questions as well for example
we've been led to believe that liba is
one of the lowest ranked devils
apparently he was born without any magic
and because of this he was brutally
mistreated by the other devils in the
underworld however his appearance and
intelligence don't seem to correspond to
the appearance and intelligence of
lowest ranked devils lower ranked devils
tend to have an appearance that is more
animalistic and beast-like and with the
lowest ranked devils in particular this
seems to extend to their behavior and
intelligence as well meanwhile highest
ranked devils are more humanoid and more
intelligent it's clear that liba's
appearance and intelligence are far
closer to high and highest ranked devils
than low and mid-ranked devils and then
there's anti-magick after being sealed
away inside the five-leaf grimoire liba
awakens anti-magic which is not only
strong against regular magic attributes
but it is also super effective against
devils it's safe to say that a lowest
ranked devil would never be able to
muster up the power to take out a
highest ranked devil like lilith and
nama and yet thanks to anti-magic liba
and asta were able to do exactly that
broke who did an entire video talking
about why liba is likely either a high
or highest ranked devil based on his
appearance and abilities and i will link
that video down in the description below
it is very interesting and makes a lot
of sense it is highly unlikely that liba
is really a lowest ranked devil based on
what we know about devils so far but if
he really is a higher ranked devil then
why was he born without any magic well
what if he wasn't really born without
magic what if he was born with one of
the most overpowered magic attributes of
all black hole magic but because of the
complex nature of this magic attribute
it takes a long time to fully manifest
what if anti-magic as we know it is just
the first step on the road to awakening
black hole magic a magic attribute that
can not only negate the magic of others
but also absorb all of it like a black
hole as we know a black hole absorbs
everything around it including entire
stars including light and everything
else and it turns all that it absorbs
into a gravitational singularity which
is a region where the space-time
curvature becomes infinite everything
that gets close enough to a black hole
is pulled into the singularity and
crushed to infinite density and if that
wasn't enough black holes have also been
associated with the possibility of
traveling in time according to some
theories if we could travel close enough
to a black hole time would actually slow
down enabling us to travel into the
future the idea is that if a spaceship
was circling around the black hole time
would slow down for the spaceship while
it continues passing at a normal rate
for everyone who isn't near the black
hole so once the spaceship decides to
pull away from the black hole and return
to where it came from it will literally
find itself in the future on top of that
several physicists have suggested that
black holes do not possess a true
mathematical singularity but rather they
possess a region of chaotic space in
which time does not exist so
time-related powers or the negation of
time-related powers as well as
potentially speeding up slowing down or
even stopping time altogether could all
be possible in some form with black hole
magic now just imagine the final battle
in the entire black clover series
imagine osta and all of his friends and
allies standing against the strongest
villain or villains that they've ever
encountered imagine the gravity spatial
and time magic devils dominating the
battle against asta and our heroes with
perhaps the time magic devil using some
insane form of time magic that no one
can counter but then asta awakens black
hole magic he is able to absorb the
magic of all of his allies including of
course you know star magic and he
condenses them all into an infinitely
powerful singularity lucifer beelzebub
and the time devil try to stop asta's
attack but because a black hole warps
gravity space and time their attacks are
ineffective
finally asta unleashes this infinite
singularity made up of all the different
absorbed magic types at the villains and
absolutely wipes them out of existence
game over man that would be absolutely
crazy and i can't wait to see how it's
all going to go down if you guys enjoyed
this theory definitely leave a like and
also leave your thoughts and feedback on
the theory down below don't forget to
subscribe and hit the bell for more
content like this and now it's time to
bring in our special guest
and now joining me is fellow anime
youtuber and black clover theorist broku
broku welcome pleasure to have you hey
what's going on thanks for having me on
very much appreciated loving the channel
for years so very excited to come on and
great video idea as well so excited for
that awesome man yeah pleasure to have
you guys check out broker's channel link
will be in the description tons of black
clover content tons of theories really
great stuff so your thoughts on this
black hole magic theory broku so i
actually think that it's a good idea and
something that i never really thought
about and you brought up the good points
of how it would go against the three top
devils and just immediately going off of
that is one thing that's interesting
about the anti-magic is that it can't
really be sensed by other characters
which would also be like the science
behind black holes in our world because
generally you can't really see them or
sense them we only know that they're
there isn't how they affect the world
around them and that's how you can kind
of see anti-magic is that it you can see
that it's affecting the anti-magic in
the physical world so that would be a
really cool parallel from anti-magic to
gravity or black holes yeah and i
mentioned this in the video as well uh a
lot of stuff about black holes that we
do know is theoretical even among the
scientific community so some scientists
might think that you know in the middle
of a black hole there's a wormhole
whereas others might think oh it's just
you know infinite mass
there's still disagreement but that's
what makes it interesting and of course
because black lore is about magic it's
not gonna be scientifically accurate if
there is a black hole magic it's just
gonna be kind of inspired by the
properties of a black hole and then
taken into that
fantastical sphere
yeah exactly and
there's a lot of different theories on
like the origins of the anti-magic and
how
liba got it and
uh if it is black hole magic or related
to it it would partially make sense
depending on if lucita osta's mom she
absorbed some of lucifero's mana so that
might be where how liba got this power
awakened maybe the combination of him
cursing inside the grimoire and then
when let's see to steal them inside the
grimoire she also maybe gifted some of
the power to him as well so we know that
black holes are super closely related to
gravity yeah gravity and absorption
because that's what black holes do right
like they have super dense gravity and
they absorb everything around them so
lychee does absorption uh compared to
lucifero's gravity yeah i didn't think
of that specifically in that sense but
that actually makes sense when you think
about it and actually the way i
came across this black hole idea
is i saw earlier you made a while ago
with that video about asta potentially
having star magic because of all the
star symbolism right the star symbolism
in his eye the star star symbolism in
the devil union mode but then it turned
out that yuno has star magic that turned
out to be his original magic so my thing
was oh man so then there's no way asta
can have star magic they're not gonna
make two rivals of the same type of
magic but then i was thinking
wait a black hole is a collapsed star so
it's almost like the anti-star magic or
like the dark version of star magic and
asta with his anti-magic and being the
rival of yuno it kind of started to make
sense and that's how the theory took
shape and
your work and your videos definitely had
a lot to do with it yeah so i think that
the black hole
or that would be austin liba's power
seems like it factually makes sense and
then also thematically as well because
also you know they always arial each
other and they're also dynamics to each
other as well or the opposites or the
shadows of each other so you know having
like the bright star magic and oscar
having black holes or just like you just
said
it would kind of be like
the parallel but also the shadow of the
opposite as well because it's black
holes are essentially collapsed stars
yes and i think with obviously austin
you are both good guys but their
kind of abilities and their origins
mirror each other in a sort of kind of
comparative way where you know yuno was
born with amazing magic and loved by
mana asta had no magic at all and yet
you know they maintained their rivalry
and friendship so that was kind of the
charm of it and you know you know having
star magic and also having black hole
magic would really go along with that
the theme yeah it goes perfectly that
actually makes me really excited for the
upcoming chapters and seeing if maybe we
will get more information on the magic
seeing as lucifer might be coming out
and because i really i can't see asta
just you know anti-magic crushing every
single strongest devil so far he's been
really effective with anti-magic against
zagred against lilith and nama but i
feel like something different has to
happen in order for him to be able to
take on all the strongest devils it's
not just gonna be like oh well here i'm
gonna kick your ass with anti-magic and
having anti-magic evolve into something
bigger like black hole magic i think
would be a cool narrative way
to take the battles up a notch
definitely and it would also just make
sense stemming off of his yuki about his
previous manga hungry joker and how all
like the physics-based stuff he did in
there and to bring in black hole and be
that to be hosta's magic
would be a really cool callback to
hungry joker as well which he has
actually a lot of callbacks to that
series in black clover itself yeah
hungry joker was actually canceled early
on right yeah yeah unfortunately but he
then ended up referencing hungry joker
many times in blacklover in cool ways
that if you really follow everything as
i know you do on your channel then you
know all those different little
references and things like that you know
i'm really glad you like the theory
broco because as i said you are
an expert theorist on black clover so
it's really cool to see you in you know
enjoying this theory any other theories
you have or speculations in general
about what asta's final form could look
like what kind of powers he might
possess
uh yeah so after you kind of give me
your idea i wanted to try and think of
it because after devil you know i really
haven't thought about much
advancements of like what his final form
would be but
i tried to think uh i don't know if
you've heard of the theory that austin
might be a devil hybrid so
there's actually a lot of evidence that
supports it as a possibility and i think
that if that is the case
it'd be something like where
with sharomi where it would be like
his hybrid state
sharmi's like in a normal state and then
she transforms into her like hybrid like
human dwarf state be similar with asta
or he actually has like a transformation
that would pair that with union and i
wouldn't be surprised if it's similar to
union except the like more armor and
then maybe four wings instead of two and
then maybe even six horns
like an evolution of the union and then
i also have a theory with that kind of
like how you know just awakened his own
power with which is star and magic
that i think austin's gonna do the same
thing but in a different way where he
uses key
to further like evolve his powers i
don't know if you have seen bleach or
red bleach but i think it could be
similar to us to use this key in a
similar fashion to full bring because
there's a lot of evidence that he can
amplify power we've seen it multiple
times and then we've seen if you lose
key if you lose life energy your like
body withers so if you can bring in more
key your body would theoretically get
stronger and he can use key to like
amplify the power of anti-magic that's
how you even discover to use the black
form i think it will be something like a
combination of that where he will have
this hybrid state awakened and then he
will use key in a brand new sense like
maybe if they ever go to the land of the
sun and he learns it way better than he
does now
then i think that it'll be a combination
of those two work maybe he brings in
more key which amplifies his muscles and
maybe he's even more buff which would be
insane and then the key actually
amplifying his anti-magic even further
making it even bigger like more armor
making the swords even bigger yeah i
mean that's really interesting because
key has been emphasized as something
that only asta and yami can really sense
and make use of in any way so i feel
like that's something that's definitely
going to come back in the future because
it hasn't been explored a lot yet it's
just been kind of
brought to our attention and i also like
the whole hybrid concept because i know
you mentioned in one of your videos that
there has to be some reason why
asta was able to survive being
in
lichita's womb for nine months whereas a
normal human being around her would have
their life force drained and one thing
you mentioned uh is that we know from
liebe
that a devil
would not have their life force drained
by lichita so if asta was some sort of
hybrid if his father was actually a
devil
then perhaps that is why he survived
being in the womb for nine months
because his life force wasn't being
drained because he was resistant to him
kind of like leave it was because of the
devil hybrid theory right yeah it's
exactly that zug red is really confused
that asta this human is running around
with a five leaf club of grandma because
he knows that those are meant for devils
which if he's a double hybrid kind of
add to that and also the fact that while
in double union even though liba only
has two horns when they're united they
have four horns yeah so it's almost like
um
liba himself is not the only one
transforming here
asta is bringing something devilish to
the table potentially as well yeah
that's what i'm thinking as a
possibility because even when they were
in union and it showed
liba's like silhouette when they're
fighting the the ancient demon he still
had two horns even while they were in
the union but uh
osta had four for sure i mean it really
feels like the story is gearing up
towards an epic climax we still have a
lot of the big devils to be introduced
properly like lucifer like beelzebub
like the time devil so there's still
time to go but it does feel like we're
gearing up towards some sort of final
showdown so it's going to be really
interesting to see where the story goes
from here and yeah like you said devil
union mode is the next the current hot
thing the current power up but i feel
like it can't be the final power up just
because there's still so much to do
against so many overpowered devils yeah
like
if he had any trouble at all against
loaf and nama then it's not gonna go
well against
devil's higher than that because you'd
assume that between each gate is a
massive power difference
and it's kind of shown because medicula
is not even in the top three and she was
only like one third manifested yes and
yet she showed power like it was like at
least on par with the fused twins
so there's got to be a huge gap between
each gate and if he struggled at all
against them then
yeah devil union itself unless if he
gets massive help it's not going to be
enough to take on higher devils let
alone the the big three devils yeah
because one thing i was thinking when
double unit was introduced was okay it
has a time limit so maybe just that time
limit will increase but i don't think
that's going to be enough at this point
it just doesn't seem like that's going
to be especially with the time devil the
time devil really scares me because
time-based powers
and an overpowered devil it seems super
super crazy and i mean you know there's
so much potential there stopping time
slowing down time uh speeding up time
traveling through time it's just so much
there and again that brings me back to
the whole black whole idea because black
holes can also
uh warp time potentially that's going to
make austin resistant to the time devil
and allow him to somehow defeat the time
devil yeah that that would make sense
because you can already assume that
if
with before awakening the black hole
power
that should be a huge weakness to time
because like in theory time would i'd
like the magical effect but also the
physical effect like how when asta was
on the magic volcano he was able to
easily redirect the fire magic but the
actual physical heat that the fire
emanated was a problem for him and same
with the salamander that he could he
could
he could attack its fire but the heat
that was the physical heat emanated was
a problem so he could probably cut the
time magic but the physical time
manipulation that happens would be an
issue but if you awaken the black hole
power and he could counter that with a
black hole that would be a very
interesting clash in a way for him to
actually counteract time devil which i
would assume would probably be called
osteroth with the way that tabata is
writing things you know that's a great
point about
the whole um
kind of idea of asta can counter magic
but time is a concept so
while if if he throws like some kind of
time magic magical attack
directly out of asta he can counter it
but if he actually stops time itself or
like travels
through time or speeds it up or slows it
down it will be very difficult for
anti-magic to counter it because it's a
concept it's not like a
energy force i'm super excited to see
what happens broken thank you so much
for being a guest on the video guys
check out broku's channel link in the
description tons of black clover content
thanks man thanks for having me on
appreciate it i want to give a big thank
you to all of our anime opera patrons
who make videos like this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma this
man is an absolute mad lad and a
disciple of lord tuigo himself and i
can't forget all of our the one tier
patrons the ones who stand above all
other clans including ingrata algital
pate heffa the red-haired fox hinokami
and water the toasted chi corey mcgowan
the spike dylan isadore spidey
liftanelle tungsten tarkis baked
buddhist monkey d quilly cody hebert and
jeremy cummings finally thank you also
to our pro hero tier patrons including
the one and only gilgamesh steelers
angel crews very gucci alicia octor
bonnie parks joy and garcia fat boy
games kaido might be a duck jessica
rabbit and jeremy phillips if you enjoy
our videos and you feel that they
provide value to you consider supporting
us on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos along with these legendary people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you